اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
[موسيقى]
الدفاع الروسيه تتحدث عن تدمير نظام
الدفاع الجوي في كييف ومنظومه باتريوت
الامريكيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي يطالب بشفافيه اكبر في
الانتخابات التركيه ومعالجه القصور في
جوله الاعاده
البرلمان الليبي يعلن اقاله رئيس الحكومه
فتحي باشاغه واحالته الى التحقيق
[موسيقى]
ارتفاع وقتل المدنيين منذ بدء الاشتباكات
في السودان الى اكثر من 800 شخص
اذا مشاهدينا نبدا الخامسه من تطورات
الحرب الاوكرانيه اكدت وزاره الدفاع
الروسي انها دمرت نظام الدفاع الجوي في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه استهدفت ايضا منظومه
باتريوت الامريكيه فياب بصاروخ كنجال فضلا
عن استهداف وحدات للقوات الاوكرانيه وايضا
مستودعات للذخيره بصواريخ عاليه الدقه
اطلقت من الجو وايضا من البحر
كما قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان الجيش
قصف مواقع الوحدات الاوكرانيه ايضا مواقع
تخزين الاسلحه المقدمه من الدول الغربيه
في هجوم صاروخيه ليليه على كيف نتابع
سنه القوات المسلحه للاتحاد الروسي ضربه
مركزه على مواقع وحدات الجيش الاوكراني
ومواقع تخزين الاسلحه والمعدات المقدمه من
الدول الغربيه لاوكرانيا وذلك عبر اسلحه
جويه وبحريه بعيده المدى وقد تحقق الهدف
بعد ضرب جميع المواقع المحدده
وقد افادت وسائل اعلام روسيه باصابه خمسه
جنود من حرس الحدود الروس بهجوم لطائره
مسيره اوكرانيه طبعا هذا الهجوم استهدف
مبنى اداري تابع لجهاز مراقبه الحدود في
منطقه كورس بقريه جلوشكوفو على الحدود مع
اوكرانيا
الرد الاوكراني ياتي طبعا عقب الهجوم
الروسي الضخم والذي استهدف العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف كما ذكرنا مسؤولون
اوكرانيون قالوا ان انفجارات وقعت في
احياء عده في الساعات الاولى من صباح هذا
اليوم اضافه طبعا الى انفجارات اخرى في
منطقه سلوميانسكي دون الاشاره الى حجم
الاضرار وايضا الخسائر الناجمه عنها من
جانبه اكد رئيس بلديه كييف في تالي
كليتشكو ان الحطام الناجم عن الانفجارات
سقط على حديقه الحيوان بالمدينه مشيرا الى
ان الحطام المتساقط اشعل النيران في عده
سيارات كان مسؤولون اوكرانيون اكدوا ان
انظمه الدفاع الجوي تصدت لهجمات جويه
روسيه على كيف واماكن اخرى في اوكرانيا
المزيد مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل اهلا بك
حذيفه اخر المعلومات المتوفر لديك
الميدانيه تفضل
مساء الخير ميسون طبعا بخصوص الضربه
الجويه التي نفذت نحو العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف استخدمت خمسه احياء في المدينه او
الاضرار يعني كانت في خمسه مناطق في
المدينه منطقه سلومنسكي منطقه شفشينسكي
منطقه دارنسكي وكذلك
سقطت فيها بعض الشظايا لم يكن هنالك يعني
اثار تذكر بسيط من الشظايا التي سقطت
تضررت بعد السيارات في الشوارع وكذلك طبعا
سقطت احد الشظايا في حديقه الحيوان وايضا
لم يكن هنالك ضرر بالغ او كبير طبعا وصف
هذا هذا الاستهداف بانه الاكبر او الاضخم
فقط نسبه لانه اكبر عدد من الصواريخ في
اقل قدر من الزمن اطلقت متزامنه مع بعضها
البعض نحو العاصمه تقول طبعا الدفاعات
الجويه وقال وصرح يورينات الناطق الرسمي
باسم الدفاع الجوي سلاح الطيران الاوكراني
قال انهم استطاعوا ان يسقطوا جميع
الصواريخ التي استهدفت العاصمه كيف 18
صاروخا منها سته من طراز قنجر
او كنجال كما يقولون
وتم اسقاطها جميعا طبعا لم يعلق بعد ان
سئل عن ما افادت لانه الجانب الروسي يتحدث
عن انه دمر
نظام الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني
وبالتالي السؤال هل كان ذلك تعليقا على
هذه التصريحات رد ونفي ام انه لا جاءت في
سياق الحديث عما يحدث على الارض بصوره
عامه
نعم يعني يمكننا ان اجيب على هذا السؤال
من من شطرين الاول ان السلطات الرسميه
الناطق الرسمي باسم سلاح الجو الاوكراني
قال بشكل واضح انني لن اعلق على ادعات
الاتحاد الروسي وعلق على الضربات عددها
ونوعيه الصواريخ التي استهدفت العاصمه كيف
هذا بالاضافه طبعا الى المسيرات وانه تم
اسقاط جميع الاهداف وهذا انا في طبعا
بالتاكيد عندما يقول تم اسقاط جميع
الاهداف هذا نفي من ان هنالك هدف استطاع
ان يصل الى احد الصواريخ استطاع ان يصل
الى هدفه وانا طبعا اعيش هنا في العاصمه
وانا موجود في العاصمه ولا يوجد اي انفجار
يذكر في العاصمه كيف ولا حتى في ضواحي
العاصمه كيف حيث الدفاعات الجويه وطبعا
الدفاعات الجويه هي موجوده داخل المدينه
هي دفعات ليست خارج المدينه فقط نعم هنالك
دفاعات جويه في الطريق الى العاصمه سواء
من الجنوب او الشمال او من جنوب الشرق
البلاد هذه المناطق التي منها يتم اطلاق
الصواريخ الصواريخ من البحر الاسود او من
مناطق سيطره القوات الروسيه في الشرق او
حتى من داخل الاراضي الرو من الشمال من
اتجاه دوله بيلاروسيا هذه المناطق هذه
المواقع التي يتم منها اطلاق الصواريخ
يوجد دفاعات جويه في تلك المناطق وفي
الطريق الى العاصمه كيف وكذلك داخل
العاصمه كيف كنا قد شاهدنا طبعا عمل
الدفاعات الجويه وكيف انها استطاعت ان
تسقط هذه الاهداف في السماء
يتحدث عن اهداء استهداف وحدات طبعا للقوات
الاوكرانيه اضافه الى مستودعات للذخيره
لدينا معلومات عن حجم الاضرار او لا
نعم فيما يخص كيف لا يوجد اي استهداف تم
بشكل كامل هنا في العاصمه اذا كنا نتحدث
عن الشرق الاوكراني لم يعني تصرح وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه او بيان هيئه الاركان
العامه المشتركه لم يذكر اي استهداف في
مستودعات الذخيره عن العكس تماما قال انهم
استطاع ان ينفذوا ضربات في عمق العدو كما
قال البيان انهم استطاعوا ان يدمروا مناطق
تمركز لوحدات وعاليات للقوات الروسيه في
العمق وكذلك تم تنفيذ ضربات جويه في عمق
مراكز تمركز القوات الروسيه وكذلك
اللوجيسيات القوات الروسيه طبعا تم تنفيذ
ضربتين صاروخيتين من قبل الاتحاد الروسي
نحو منطقه كسنتينا وهذا ما اقرت به وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه انا اتوقع طبعا بحسب
خبرتي وبحسب معرفتي بالمنطقه وقد زرتها
اكثر من مره في وقت القتال هي منطقه يكون
فيها في الغالب مستودعات ويكون فيها مراكز
لوجستيه لان ها قريبه جدا من الجبهه قد
يكون هذا هو السبب الذي جعل القوات
الروسيه تستهدف منطقه
بالتحديد طبعا اليوم الكساندرز سيرتي وهو
قائد القوات البريه كان في زياره الى بخبط
وتحدث اذا كان لديك مزيدا من وقت يمكنني
ان اطلعك على وضع الجبهه ربما في نشرتنا
اللاحقه من العربيه حذيفه عادل شكرا جزيلا
لك
على امل جمع معلومات استخباراتيه عن بوتين
وعن ايضا حكومته تحاول وكاله الاستخبارات
الامريكيه الوصول مباشره الى المواطنين
الروس خاصه الناقمين على وضع بلادهم
الحليب بسبب الحرب فمنذ بدء الصراع في
اوكرانيا زعم المسؤولون الامريكيون ان
سكان الروس يحاولون التواصل معهم لشرح
المظالم التي يواجهونها في بلادهم وفقا
لصحيفه واشنطن بوست الصحيفه اضافت ان
الياس بلغ ذروته مع الروس لدرجه انهم
توجهوا الى السفارات الامريكيه لعرض
مشاكلهم بل اكثر من ذلك طلب المساعده حتى
من مواطنين امريكيين في الشوارع الولايات
المتحده اعربت عن قلقها من هذا النهج غير
الامن للتواصل وقدمت بديلا في منشور حديث
على تيليجرام وتويتر نشرت وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه الامريكيه تعليمات واضحه وباللغه
الروسيه حول كيفيه تواصل المواطنين الروس
مباشره بالوكاله عبر
وعلى وجه التحديد متصفح الانترنت تور الذي
يتيح للمستخدمين تبادل المعلومات دون
الكشف عن هويتهم
تخاطب المواطنين الروس مقطع من دقيقتين
نشرته
الروسيه تيليجرام تحد خلاله الروس على كشف
معلومات عن بلادهم المقطع يظهر عائله
روسيه محبطه من سياسه بوتين المحتوى يحاول
التاكيد على الحس الوطني للعائله ويشجع
الروس للافصاح عن معلومات في مختلف
المجالات الوكاله في الفيديو قالت نريد
معرفه الحقيقه في روسيا وتبعث سي اي اي
رساله بالروسيه مفادها نبحث عن اشخاص
موثوقين للادلاء بشهاداتهم الاستخبارات
شددت على توفير منفذ امن للمتحدثين مصادر
قالت ان الدعايه واشنطن لا تهدف لتغيير
النظام في موسكو
للمزيد معنا من موسكو الينا سوفنينا
المستشاره السياسيه في مركز الدراسات
الدوليه اهلا بك السيده ايلينا بدايه هو
ليست المحاوله الاولى وان كان الطريقه في
الطرح جديده مقرره بسابقتها بعد بدء الحرب
في اوكرانيا وبالتالي السؤال كيف تقرئين
هذه الرساله هل هي تاتي بمنظور جديد وطرح
جديد من الجانب الامريكي ما وراءها
مرحبا بكم صحيح هذه هي ليست محاوله اولى
ولكن هي اولى من نوع لانه بكل الصراحه
امريكان الان ينشرون دعايات من اجل تجنيد
مواطنين
هذا عن طريق
تغريد في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وحتى
على مستوى
الاستخبارات الامريكيه الاساسيه وايضا
بنشر مثل المقالات المذكوره في صحف
امريكيه مختلفه انا لا اصدق
انه مواطنين رؤوس مثلا
يطالبون بمساعدات بالمساعدات من قبل
الامريكان في شوارع انا لا استطيع ان
اتصور ذلك فهي يعني سيده لينا تقولين ان
ربما يكون هناك نوع من المبالغه ولكن هل
هذا يمنع من ان يكون بالفعل هناك من يحاول
التواصل مع الولايات المتحده وبالتالي كما
تقول انه بناء على نجاح الحمله الاولى هي
بدات بتدشين الحمله الثانيه
هناك ممكن من
يستجيب هذه الدعوات من
المعارضه الروسيه وهي
جدا ولكن هناك بعض الناس هم حتى الان
يتعاونون مع الغرب من اجل اضعاف النظام في
روسيا هذا وارد جدا امريكان الان يراهنون
على معارضين قبل كل شيء
ولديهم اهداف مختلفه وهو جمع
معلوماتيه ولكن ايضا
العمل من اجل اضعاف السلطه المركزيه في
روسيا هل سينجح الى اي حد ما يقومون به
خطر جدا على موسكو الان
انا ما بعتقد انه ممكن ان ينجحوا بهذه
الطريقه لان هذه الطريقه هي
لن تمشي مع رؤوس هذه المبالغات هي جديه
وهي تعكس عدم فهم النفسيه الروسيه
السيكولوجيه الروسيه ايضا لا يفهمون بانه
الناس لحتى الان هم ملتفين حول السلطه
وكلما امريكان يضغطون اكثر كلما مع هذه
الوحده ام تزيد لانه عنا في روسيا
توجد عداء ومعينه نحو الامريكان وعدم
الثقه تجاهه والسيده ايلينا بحسب قراءه
البعض لهذا الفيديو وهذه الحمله فانه
المستهدف محدود هم لا يتحدثون عن الروس
بصوره عامه ولكن اناس باماكن معينه ومحدده
نعم هنا لا استطيع ان اتفق ان توجد نقطه
الضعف رغم تشديد العقوبات في داخل روسيا
ضد هؤلاء او ضد التجسس بشكل عام ولكن بعض
الناس قد غادروا البلاد بعد الناس غادروا
البلاد بسبب التجنيد مثلا والتعبئه
العسكريه بعضهم لا يريدون العوده الى
روسيا بعضهم يميلون للمعارضه
فهذه الدوائر ممكن ان تبحث امريكا عن
حلفاء طيب وعندما نستمع الى او نشاهد هذا
الفيديو نلاحظ بانه كان هناك نوع من
التغاضي عن ذكر ان كان بوتين شخصيا او
فيما يتعلق باوكرانيا لسبب الاساسي برايك
هو للاستمراريه في العمل
بهذه الحمله ام انه لا هناك بعض المحظورات
وهم بداوا هذيك الحمله حتى قبل احداث
اوكرانيا
فالان هناك تحاول نوعي انه هم
بكل الصراحه بصراحه لا اكثر بالمقارنه مع
الماضي ولكنهم اكيد يريدون ان يستمروا وان
نحن راينا في التسعينات مباشره بعد
تفكك الاتحاد السوفيتي راينا
اختراقات خطيره جدا في داخل المجتمع
الروسي واخطر من ذلك في داخل الدوائر
السياسيه الروسيه
كانت معنا من موسكو ايلينا المستشاره
السياسيه في مركز الدراسات الدوليه شكرا
جزيلا لك
كشفت الولايات المتحده ارقام تراسانتها
الاستراتيجيه للردع النووي في وقت اكدت
انها تريد احترام معاهده نيوستات لنزع
السلاح النووي طبعا فرصه استغلتها واشنطن
لدعوه روسيا الى احترام هذه المعاهده وفي
هذا التقرير نتعرف اساسا على حجم الترسانه
النوويه الروسيه نتابع
دعوه واشنطن لموسكو بالعوده الى معاهده
اليوستارت للحد من الاسلحه النوويه لن تجد
اذانا صاغيه في الكرملين في الوقت الحالي
على الاقل روسيا التي ورثت اسلحه الاتحاد
السوفيتي النوويه تمتلك اكبر مخزون في
العالم من الرؤوس الحربيه النوويه
التقديرات تقول ان لدى روسيا نحو 400
صاروخ باليستي عابر للقارات مسلحه نوويا
يمكنها ان تحمل ما يصل الى
1185 راسا حربيا روسيا تدير ايضا 10
غواصات مسلحه نوويا يمكنها ان تحمل 800
راس حربي كحد اقصى كما انها تملك ما بين
60 وسبعين قاذفه نوويه
الحرب في اوكرانيا اعادت عقارب الزمن الى
فتره الحرب البارده فتره تسابق خلالها
المعسكران الشرقي والغربي نحو التسلح
حينها امتلك الاتحاد السوفيتي 40 الف راس
فيما امتلكت الولايات المتحده 30 الف بلال
البشتين العربيه
قال نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيس ان روسيا
لا تناقش قضايا العقوبات مع واشنطن ولا
توجد ماده للنقاش مع الولايات المتحده في
موضوع العقوبات وتبادل الاسرى مضيفا ان
الخطاب الامريكي بشان مساله العقوبات لا
يمكن ان يسبب شيء سوى الرفض اعتبر المسؤول
الروسي ان لا عوده حاليا الى معاهده
السلاح التقليدي وان البدائل قد تظهر فقط
عندما يتغير الوضع في العالم
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
الاتحاد الاوروبي يطالب بشفافيه اكبر في
الانتخابات التركيه ومعالجه القصور في
جوله الاعاده
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه اوجه قصور في
الانتخابات التركيه حددتها منظمه الامن
والتعاون الاوروبي من خلال بعثتها لمراقبه
العمليه الانتخابيه مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه التي اتحاد الاوروبيه خاطب
السلطات التركيه لضمان توفير الفرص
العادله للمنافسين خلال جوله الاعاده فقبل
انطلاق الاستحقاق الانتخابي في تركيا تلقت
منصه تويتر اوامر قضائيه من انقره لحجب
بعض الحسابات وايضا التغريدات التي تنتهك
القواعد الانتخابيه وتمثل ما تعتبره
تهديدا للامن القومي القضيه بدات عندما
اتهمت السلطات التركيه تويتر باتاحه
خدماتها خلال الانتخابات التي جرت لاحد
الماضي على الرغم من التحذيرات لاحقا
دافعت تويتر عن موقعها وموقفها بانها
استجابت بالفعل لجزء من طلبات انقره قبل
يوم من الانتخابات وذلك بحجم اربعه حسابات
واكثر من تغريده حددتها المحكمه التركيه
طبعا حاله الجدل حول اجراء تويتر دفع
خبراء الحقوق الالكترونيه الاتهام الشركه
بانها باتت تتماهى في عهد ايلون ماسك مع
القرارات الحكوميه اصبحت اكثر اتجاها
لتقييد حريه التعبير تويتر عادت ودافعت عن
موقفها ايضا بانه كان اجراء احترازي
واستجابه جزئيه لطلبات السلطات في انقره
حتى لا تتعرض خدماتها في تركيا للانقطاع
يذكر ان الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات
التركيه شهدت تقدما لاردوغان على منافسه
كمال كليتش دار اوغلو قبل ان يدخل
المرشحان الى جوله اعاده في الثامن
والعشرين من مايو الجاريه طبعا هذا وعقدت
اللجنه التنفيذيه المركزيه لحزب العداله
والتنميه التركيه اجتماعا برئاسه زعيم
الحزب الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان في العاصمه
انقر هذا الاجتماع الذي انعقد بعيدا عن
وسائل الاعلام واستغرق ثلاث ساعات خصص
لتقييم الانتخابات البرلم انيه والرئاسيه
الاخيره التي شهدتها تركيا كما ناقشت
تحضيرات اللازمه للجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات في 28 من مايو الجاريه
المزيد معنا من اسطنبول طاهر بركه موفد
العربيه الى هناك من انقره مراسل العربيه
زيدان زنكلو اهلا بك وما ابدا معك طاهر
واخر التحركات لاردوغان واللقاءات
اهلا بك ميسون كما ذكرتي اللقاءات على قدم
وساقع على جانبي الموالاه والمعارضه فيما
يتعلق بالرئيس اردوغان كانت لقاءاته
الابرز مع دوله بهشه لحليفو وهو زعيم
الحركه القوميه ربما لمناقشه كيف يمكن
التحرك في المرحله الثانيه من الانتخابات
في هذين الاسبوعين خاصه لاشتذاب اصوات
سنان اوغان التي ذهبت اليه في الجوله
الاولى اضافه الى عدد من حلفائه في
التحالف تحالف الجمهور الذي يقوده وعلى
راسهم رئيس حزب اليسار الديمقراطي نحن
امام ايام حاسمه تجتمع فيها الموالاه مع
حلفائها والمعارضه مع حلفائها المحاوله
تجميع
الصفوف كل منهما المعارضه ايضا تلتقي تمت
اقاله مديري حمله كليتش دار اوغلو
الانتخابيه وهما علي كريميتشي اوغلو واكان
عبد الله وحل محلهما رئيس اسطنبول اكرم
امام اوغلو ورئيسه الحزب حزب الشعب
الجمهوري في اسطنبول جنان كفتنجي لقياده
هذه الحمله اسطنبول التي مكادت حمله
الانتخابات الاولى يعني تخفض حدتها مع يوم
النتائج حتى اشتعلت من جديد وعلت حدتها في
اليوم الاول يمكن ان نعتبره من الحملات
الانتخابيه التي بداها ايضا سليمان سويلو
بالمرور والتجوال في مقرات حزب العداله
والتنميه وكذلك في الشوارع وبين الناس
يعدون
حلفائهم وانصارهم بالفوز في الجوله
الثانيه
نجعل ايضا عن الخطابات ومن هو المستهدف
الان هي الجوله الثانيه زيدان هناك من
يقول انه اردوغان يتوجه
لمن نجا من الزلزال اما بالنسبه للمعارضه
فالشباب هو المستهدف
لم اسمع السؤال ميسون
هل تسمعني
عن الجمهور الذي يستهدفه ان كان اردوغان
من جهه لانه البعض يقول انه خطابه يتوجه
مباشره في هذه الفتره لمن يعيشون في منطقه
الزلزال ومن نجوا منه واما المعارضه فهي
تركز اكثر على الشباب
نعم بالضبط ميسون بدايه ساعطي التحديثات
التي قالها الزميل طاهر في هذه الاثناء
يجتمع الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان مع
حديثه زعيم حزب الحركه القوميه دوله
باتشيلي قبل ربع ساعه بدا هذا الاجتماع في
القصر الرئاسي الذي نقف على مقربه منه
وهنا في مقر حزب العداله والتنميه الذي
نتواجد بجانبه الان ايضا اجتماع
او يسمى اجتماع استراتيجي بقياده نائب
رئيس الحزب نعمان كرت المش للتحضير للجوله
القادمه وفي الرد على سؤالك هذا الموضوع
يتم نقاشه الان موضوع زيارات الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان بحسب التسريبات
التي صدرت عن اجتماع امس والتحضيرات
الاجتماع اليوم من المقرر ان يزور الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان مناطق الزلزال مره
اخرى في
الايام القادمه وايضا الولايات التي كان
قريبا او نسبه اصوات الرئيس التركي قريبه
من مرشح المعارضه كمالك الجدار اوكلو ايضا
سيكون هناك تركيز في الحملات الانتخابيه
على نفس السيناريو الذي كان متبعا في
الحمله الاولى وتحديدا علاقه
حزب الشعب الجمهوري ومرشح المعارضه كماركل
جدار اوغلو مع حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي على
ما يبدو ان هذه الدعايه كانت تثير
القوميين بشكل ايجابي يعني او يعني حماسه
القوميه بشكل ايجابي للتصويت ضد كل جدار
اوكلو وهذا ما نقلته وايضا مصادر المعرف
الاجتماع الاخر الذي يجري ايضا اليوم في
مقر حزب الشعب الجمهوري هنا في العاصمه
انقره من خلال كواليس الاجتماعات التي
استطعنا يعني متابعتها من مصادر المعارضه
سواء اجتماع امس ايضا كان هناك اجتماعيه
المجلس المركزي لحزب الشعب الجمله واليوم
خلال الاجتماعات كان هناك تركيز من قيادات
حزب الشعب الجمهوري على ان الحمله
الدعائيه كانت ضعيفه في الرد على مزاعم او
ما قالوا انها مزاعم الرئيس التركي
والفريق الاعلامي ضعيفه ولكن كيف
يمكن تصحيحها يمكن هاي المعضل الرئيسيه
الموجوده هنا انتقل لطاهر لمعرفه ردود فعل
الشارع وهل هناك بالفعل نوع من الشهيه
للعوده الى جوله ثانيه في الانتخابات طاهر
هناك شهيه كبيره ميسون بدون شك يعني
الموالاه تحاول ان تشحذ همم مناصريها
للدفع بهم الى دخول تركيا المئويه الثانيه
كما قال اردوغان قال لنجعل الثامن
والعشرين من مايو يوم جوله الاعاده بدايه
دخول تركيا مئويتها الثانيه اذن هناك حماس
كبير ولكن بالنسبه الى المعارضه بانتظار
ما تؤول عنه هذه الاجتماعات هناك غضب في
داخل المعارضه هناك تحميل مسؤوليات هناك
مراجعه للحسابات فيما يتعلق بالارقام التي
حازت عليها هناك مثلا اعتقاد بان انسحاب
ميرا الاكشنر زعيمه حزب الخير قبل ان تعود
الى الطاوله الاسيه كان له اثر في ما الت
اليه النتائج ايضا شخصيه كليتش
وبعض ما يوصف الاخطاء التي وقع فيها فيما
يتعلق بمحاوله استماله المحافظين او
التيارات الدينيه وخاصه فيما يتعلق بمرحله
ما بعد تحالف احمد داود اوغلو زعيم حزب
المستقبل وعلي بابا جان رئيس حزب
الديمقراطيه والتقدم معه وهمام شقان عن
حزب العداله والتنميه حتى ان المولات ترصد
له اخطاء فيما يتعلق بسرد بعض الايات
والاحاديث النبويه الشريفه وتعلق عليه
بانه بعيد اصلا عن هذا المجال وهو لديه
تعتبره انه لديه يعني مشكله في مواضيع
اساسيه بالنسبه الى المحافظين مثل الحجاب
وغيره وبالتالي حاول ان يلعب في ملعب غيره
وهذه جمله زيدان زيدان في انقره التي يعني
افاد افادني بها جدا عندما شرح لي هذه
النقطه تحديدا عندما سالته كيف يعني يمكن
التعليق على هذا الموضوع باستفاضه لانه
واضح ان هناك حنق هناك غضب من بعض
التحالفات في هذا الشق الاخر من المعارضه
بالنسبه الى تحالف مع العقاد او مع
المحافظين اذا مصحه تعبير طاهر ولكن اعود
الى زي دان كونه غاز في هذه النقطه انا
بيهمني اعرف انه العناوين الرئيسيه خلال
الانتخابات كانت الجانب الاقتصادي تحدثنا
عن الزلزال وغيره ولكن عندما نتحدث عن
التغيير الحقيقي الذي يمكن ان يكون او
تفرضوا المعارضه كيف له ان يؤثر على الناس
على الارض وعلى شكل الدوله بصوره عامه
زيدان
نعم اعتقد ان المعارضه اخطات في عده
مواضيع اولا طبعا اختيار شخصيه المرشح
كمالك الجدار اوغلو بالنسبه لكثير من
الجيل الشاب من انصار المعارضه اتحدث
كانوا يتامنون او كانوا ينظرون الى رئيس
بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو كوجهه
للتغيير اولا في خطاب حزب الشعب الجمهوري
وايضا في طريقه تعاطيه مع القضايا الحساسه
وقضايا القرن الحادي والعشرين بالتالي كان
هناك حاله احباط اولا من هذه الناحيه ايضا
الناحيه الاخرى
موضوع وكما ذكر الزميل طاهر ان يتقرب بشكل
كبير من المحافظين كمال كالجدار اوغلو
ويؤدي ويذهب الى المسجد وكما علق اردوغان
على هذه النقطه وقال بات يصلي الجمعه اكثر
مني في هذه النقطه
اثار حنق الكثير من الاتاتوركين اذا
سميناهم وهم العلمانيين المؤيدين لحزب
الشعب الجمهوري اثار يعني استياء الكثير
كيف لزعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري ممثل
الاتاتوركيه والكماليه والعلمانيه في
تركيا ان يؤدي هذه التصرفات فهو لا ارضى
المحافظين ولم يرضي العلمانيين والقوميين
ايضا بتحالفه مع حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
لذلك العامل الاساسي بعيدا عن
الايديولوجيا التي اشتغل عليها حزب الشعب
الجمهوري واعتقد انه نجح بها بها بشكل
نسبي في اسطنبول وانقره فقط هو العامل
الاقتصادي حيث تعاني هاتين المدينتين من
اضرار التدخل التضخم عفوا وغلاء المعيشه
اكثر من بقيه المدن في وسط تركيا وفي جنوب
تركيا ايضا موضوع الزلزال لم تنجح
المعارضه في ان تخاطب متضرري الزلزال بشكل
ايجابي كالخطاب الذي قدمه الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان يعني حقيقه انا منذ
الايام الاولى لحدود الزلزال اشخاص كثر
كانوا ضد اردوغان في مناطق الزلزال لكن
قالوا اننا سنسوق له في الانتخابات
القادمه نخاف من المجهول نخاف الله يتم
تعويضنا من قبل الجهه او التيار الذي
سيحكم تركيا
مستقبلاص العربيه زيدان شكرا جزيلا لكم من
اسطنبول طاهر بركه موفد العربيه الى هناك
شكرا جزيلا لك
شدد المبعوث الاممي الى ليبيا عبد الله
بتيلي على ضروره اشراك كافه اصحاب المصلحه
بمن فيهم القاده الليبيين في العمليه
الانتخابيه مشيرا الى ان الانتخابات
المقبله ستجرى اذا توفرت الاراده والرغبه
لدى كافه الاطراف نتابع
وهذه القضايا لاكثر من سنتين
واذا كان هناك
نيه حسنه وكذلك التزام سياسي واخلاقي
حقيقي وكذلك اذا ما اتخذ القرار
بالاستجابه لنداء الشعبي الليبي فلا ارى
اي سبب يمنع عقده هذه الانتخابات وطبعا
الانتخابات لا تقتصر على القانون
الانتخابي وكذلك هي لا تقتصر على
الاتفاقات السياسيه كما انها لا تخص فقط
القاعده
الدستوريه وانما تعني اشراك الشعب الليبي
وكذلك كافه الاطراف ذات العلاقه ولذلك قلت
بانه ينبغي علينا اشراك كافه اصحاب
المصلحه بما في ذلك على سبيل المثال
القاده الامنيين
كما حذر الموت الاممي الى ليبيا من تعرض
ليبيا الى التفت وايضا الانقسام اذا
استمرت حاله الاختلاف السياسي
والشعب الليبي قد سئم من انقسام هذه
المؤسسات وهم سئموا ايضا من وضع
يواجهون فيه
مخاطر بشان السياده الوطنيه ووحده الاراضي
الليبيه وهذه المخاطر سوف تزداد في ظل هذه
الاوضاع الانتقاليه وعلاوه على ذلك فيمكن
او ندعو ان لا يحدث ذلك ندعو الله العلي
القدير الا يحدث هذا لكن البلاد سوف تتفتت
وتنقسم
وبالتالي فان هذا الوضع سوف يكون على حساب
الشعب الليبي
على سؤال للعربيه بشان ترشح حفتر وسيف
الاسلام للانتخابات المقبله قال المبعوث
الاممي الى ليبيا انه لا يجب ان يستثنى
احد من العمليه الانتخابيه ما المقاربه
الاميه المتعلقه بشروط الترشح هل من
المفترض او من الضروري ان يسمح للعسكريين
ولوجوه النظام السابق بان يترشحوا
للرئاسيات ونقصد هنا بالتاكيد خليفه حفتر
سيف الاسلام القذافي وغيرهم من الشخصيات
بالتاكيد
ادركوا ان سمت قضاي جدليه بما في ذلك
معايير الترشح للانتخابات
ولكن فيما يخص بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم
في ليبيا
الانتخابات حتى تكون
ممثله لاراده الشعب الليبي ومن اجل توصل
الى
استقرار بفضل هذه الانتخابات هذه
الانتخابات يجب ان لا تستثني احدا
مراسل العربيه محمد مسعود اهلا بك محمد
بدايه ما خلفيات عمليه او قرار الايقاف
بالنسبه الى باش اغا
هي خطوه كانت متوقعه لدى كل الاوساط هنا
في ليبيا او حتى لدى الشارع بعد ان طفى
الخلاف ما بين عدد من اعضاء مجلس النواب
ومن بين رئيسه الحكومه السيد فتحي اغا هذا
الخلاف يرجع مرده الى امرين في البدايه
هناك عدد كبير من اعضاء مجلس النواب يرون
ان السيد فتحي قد منح الثقه من اجل الدخول
الى العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس تعاهد به قبل
ترشيحه لنفسه ليتبوء هذا المنصب وبالتالي
فان عدد من هؤلاء الاعضاء قد صوتوا له
بمنح الثقه لحكومته بهذا الاجراء او او
مقابل ضمان الدخول الى العاصمه الليبيه
طرابلس واستلام مقاليد السلطه والحكم هناك
الامر الاخر هناك خلاف على عدد من
الميزانيات والاموال التي يتم بمجابها
تحويلها الى عدد من البلديات شرقا وغربا
وجنوبا ومطالبه بعض اعضاء مجلس النواب
بمحاسبه رئيسه الحكومه على طريقه الصرف
على هذه البلده البلديات في حين ين رئيس
الحكومه كل هذه
الاتهامات ولكن هاتين الجبهتين او هاتين
الفئتين من اعضاء مجلس النواب توحدتان
لتشكل جبهه قويه ضد رئيسه الحكومه السيد
فتحي ادى الى قناع عدد اخر من النواب جلسه
هذا اليوم وايقافه عن العمل وكل هذه
النقاط هي ما تسببت فيما وصلنا اليه في
هذا اليوم وهو ايقاف عن العمل واحاله الى
التحقيق وليس سحب بالثقه باعتبار ان السحب
الثقه ميسون يتطلب وجود او وجوب نصاب
قانوني في هذه ردود الفعل محمد
ردود الفعل كعاده الملف البي هيات متباينه
هناك على عدد كبير من اعضاء مجلس النواب
يرحبون بهذا القرار وحتى
القرار وهناك من
هناك في الشارع بان هذه الخطوه لن تغير
شيء في المشهد او في المعادله السياسيه
الليبيه باعتبار ان حاله انقسام لا تزال
مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه الان وهناك من يرى
بان التكليف شخصيه فاعله ونشطه وزير
التخطيط والماليه الدكتور اسامه حماد قد
يغير مجريات الوضع لدى هذه الحكومه
ويجعلها اكثر فاعليه ومرونه في هذا الظرف
السياسي او حتى في حاله يعني التوافق ما
بين كل المسارات الامنيه والعسكريه الاخرى
وهناك من يرى بان هذا الامر لن يغير شيء
في الواقع السياسي او في المشهد السياسي
الليبي وكل يتمسك برايه حيال هذا الامر
اما بالدعم لهذا القرار واحاله الى
التحقيق او حتى
بقبول تكليف هذه الشخصيه التي يعتبر من
اكثر الوزراء فاعليه في حكومه السيد باشا
على الاقل حتى هذه اللحظه اين هو من كل
هذا ردود الفعل المتوقعه هل من خطوات
متوقعه من قبله
قام بخطوه استباقيه قبل صدور هذا القرار
بدقائق معدوده فقط باصداره قرارا بتكليف
نائبه الاول السيد حسين او السيد علي
القطراني بمهام رئيس الحكومه وما يراه
الكل هنا هو ضرب لقرار مجلس النواب او حتى
ضرب للعلاقات الداخليه من بين النواب
انفسهم فكيلا الرجلين سوى المكلف من قبل
البرلمان الدكتور اسامه حماد او حتى شخصيه
التي كلفها القطراني هما من نفس
المنطقه اي من اقليم شرقة البلاد وبالتالي
يرى البعض بان هذا القرار كان مدروسه من
قبل بشاغه لكي يضرب الجبهه الداخليه في من
يعني اصر على اقالته في نهايه المطاف بعد
كل هذا الخلاف ولكن مجلس النواب يرى بانه
باعتباره هو الجيل الذي كلفت يعني الرئيس
الحكومه السيد باشا فقرار السيد بشاغه
بتكليف نائبه يعتبر لاغن وكانه لم يكن
وقرار السلطه التشريعيه هو الذي يفترض ان
يسري من الان فصاعدا بتكليف الدكتور اسامه
حماد وزير الماليه وتخطيط بهذا المنصب
مكان او بدلا عن باش اغازي مراسل العربيه
محمد مسعود شكرا جزيلا لك
نكمل الخامسه من السودان وتطورات الاقتتال
بين الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع حيث
ارتفع عدد القتلى المدنيين جراء
الاشتباكات المسلحه في السودان بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع الى
822 شخصا طبعا هذا وفق نقابه اطباء
السودان قالت النقابه في بيان لها ان
استمرار الاشتباكات ادى الى سقوط مزيد من
الضحايا في العاصمه الخرطوم وعدد من
الولايات
بعد خروج المنظمات العامله في حقل
الانساني بمعسكرات النزوح باقليم دارفور
شكى عدد من النازحين داخل معسكر تيم بشرق
دارفور من انعدام المساعدات وايضا الحصول
على المياه والصحه
نتواجد اليوم هنا في معسكر النيم للنازحين
بولايه شرق دارفور وهو احد معسكرات اقليمي
دارفور للنازحين الازمه السودانيه الدائره
بين الجيش والدعم السريع الغت باظلالها
على واقع المعسكر خاصه بعد خروج عدد كبير
من المنظمات العامله في الحقل الانساني
كما نتابع هنالك تكدس كبير جدا في موارد
المياه بسبب نقص الوقود وايضا بسبب عدم
وجود تشغيل لهذه المحطات التي تعمل في
مجال السوغية للمعسكر هنالك معاناه ايضا
في شتى المجالات الصحيه والانسانيه
بس دمعه دمويه الزحمه دي عدم المويه اذا
كان المويه في الزحمه ما بيكون فيه
دارينا
جاز يجي والكارب يشتغل اثنين نفس
ويضم معسكر النيم للنازحين ما يزيد عن 100
الف نازح يتوزعون في مربعات محدوده يعانون
نقصا في الغذاء والدواء بسبب تدهور
الاوضاع في السودان بعد الاحداث التي حصلت
فيهم 15 الى يومنا هذا اصبح المواطن في
معسكر النيل في مستوى واحد
كله مستوى واحد لانهم تحت السفر من حيث
المعاناه لا وجود لاي حركه بالدخل ولا في
مدخل ولا حتى الناس اللي شويه عندهم يعني
حبه اعمال تجاره شنو الان معاناه بشكل
يساوي تسعه وتسعين وتسعه
كما يتخوف سكان المعسكر من الانفلات
الامني خاصه عمليات السلب والنهب التي
يستخدم فيها السلاح والله جدا
والمواطنين فروا
ناس
يستقروا والله
من هنا
ايضا
اذا لم تعود الاوضاع في السودان الى
الواقع الذي كانت عليه ربما يتوسع شبح
المجاعه ليشمل المدن والاحياء التي تعاني
الان في جوانب عديده بجانب معسكرات النزوح
الممتده في عدد من المدن باقليم دارفور
الخمس ولكن
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا نكمل الخامسه من تونس حيث
قضت محكمه مختصه في قضايا الارهاب بسجن
راشد الغنوشي رئيس حركه النهضه لمده عام
وتغريمه ذكرت المحكمه ان الغنوشي اذينا
غيابيا لوصف الاجهزه الامنيه بالطواغيت
الامر الذي يندرج ضمن افعال مجرمه وفقا
للقانون التونسي واعتبرته تحريضا على
استهداف قوات الامن
رئيس حزب النهضه التونسي راشد الغنوشي
والذي واجه العديد من القضايا في بلاده
ومنها في الخامس من يونيو 2022 تعرضت
ارصدته للتجميل وفي السابع والعشرين من
نفس الشهر والعام منع من السفر للتحقيق
معه في اتهامات حول اغتيالات سياسيه وقعت
عام 2013
وفي التاسع عشر من يوليو 2022 تم التحقيق
معه في تهم تتعلق بالفساد المالي وفي
الحادي والعشرين من سبتمبر 2022 تعرض
للتحقيق في تهم تتعلق بالارهاب وفي العاشر
من نوفمبر من العام نفسه خضع للتحقيق في
اتهام حول تبييض الاموال
وفي الثامن والعشرين من نوفمبر 2022 مثل
للتحقيق بتهمه تسفير متطرفين الى سوريا
والعراق وفي الخامسه عشر من شهر مايو عام
2023 الجاري كانت اخر القضايا التي طالت
الغنوشي والتي حكم على اثرها بالسجن
والغرامه بتهمه التحريض على الامن وتمجيد
الارهاب
عن عمر نهز 52 عاما توفي الفنانه السعودي
فهد الحيان بعد اصابته بازمه قلبيه مفاجئه
الحياه كان رمزا من رموز الكوميديا
السعوديه مسلسل طاش اولى تجاربه الانتاجيه
واحد ابرز اعمالهم مسلسل شمشم الذي ادى
بطولته منذ عام 2006 نتابع
كتكوت
رحل هازار وانتهى مشوار فني بدا في العام
للفنان السعودي فهد الحيان الذي وافته
المنيه اثر سكته قلبيه مساء الاحد الدجاج
كان مسلسل طاش ما طاش بدايه انطلاقته
لمشواره الفني وعرفه الجمهور من خلال عاده
من الشخصيات الكوميديه اشهرها ازار التي
احبها الصغير والكبير ليبدا بعدها بحصد
النجوميه ويشارك في عدد من الاعمال وعلى
سبيل المثال من الحصر خلك معي ابو
العصافير وهشتقه ومسلسل من ناوفينا
وفي العام 2006 انتج مسلسل غشمشم الذي حظي
فيه بدور البطوله وامتد لسته مواسم اب
[موسيقى]
وي ولا تركي
ولا تركيش
مسيره فنيه حافله وسخت في ذاكره الجماهيره
بشخصيات متعدده اشهرها هازار ورويشد
وغشمتم ارتفعت بعد وفاته الدعوات وتزاحم
التعازي الوسط الفني في الوطن العربي كافه
لتعزيه ذوي الفنان فهد الحيان الذي ترك
ارثا فنيا خالدا في الاذهان
من الرياض محمد خالد العربيه
خامس انتهت لهذا اليوم نلتقي غدا ونشره
جديده مشاهدينا
ابقوا
معنا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات